hi i'm ryan and today i'm super excited
to talk about powering api operations
with ai and
ml let's get to it
[Music]
so why is api operations important well
apis are packages of data and
functionality that developers use to
build new digital experiences quickly
and easily
since they encompass business critical
information it's extremely important for
operations teams to ensure that apis are
always available
and performing as expected but as api
programs scale
it becomes practically impossible to
manage individual apis
to reduce manual overhead on operators
apogee brings the power of google's
industry-leading ai and machine learning
to your apis
a great example of such a use case is
anomaly detection
anomaly detection applies ai-powered
rules that trigger alerts based on a set
of predefined conditions
this eliminates the need for operators
to manually adjust the monitoring
thresholds on apis
as api traffic changes by season auto
address of thresholds reduces a lot of
false alert noise
therefore operators can now focus on
things that really matter to their
business
let's take a closer look at this feature
you can view
all anomaly events under the api
monitoring menu of apigee
it shows a complete list of anomalies
identified by apogee
using the power of machine learning
these events are auto-generated based on
historical api data
this eliminates the need for users to
manually set up alerts
the actionable link on each of these
events will take you to an investigate
view of the anomaly
here you can see that the error rate
surged at around 4 o'clock and the
system was able to catch the anomaly
below the graph you can see the fault
code which shows the root cause of this
anomaly
you can further investigate this event
by adding more layers such as api proxy
this shows the details of the proxy for
which this event was triggered
you can also use this analysis to
identify the source of the error
in this case you can see that the fault
source of the proxy is the apogee
platform
in addition to the system generated
events you can also set up alerts to get
real-time notifications when anomaly
events are triggered
the alert can be set up by creating an
alert policy in google cloud's
monitoring service
once an alert is triggered you will get
a notification
here is a snapshot of an email alert it
provides complete details of the anomaly
such as timestamp
project policy and threshold limits
users can click on the view incident
button to quickly investigate and find
the root cause of the error
in summary apogee brings the power of
google's industry-leading ai with
features like anomaly detection
to simplify api operations so that you
can deliver seamless and connected
experiences for your customers
now it's your turn to try it out and get
started by following the links in the
description below
you